Playing audio in the car is another
key feature of Android Auto.
You can use either the touchscreen to
select songs based on a variety of
criteria, or you can use your voice
to speak the name of a song or
artist using the voice button
on the steering wheel.
This is great because the user is
driving a car meaning they need minimal
distractions and they need to
keep their eyes on the road.
So let's take a quick look at
what it looks like to play
audio with Android Auto.
And then I'll show you
how to implement this.
So here's our universal media player
sample app, which is installed and
running on my phone here.
Android Auto is able to
connect to the app and
then browse through
the media collection.
The user can perform a search
using voice commands.
Play music jazz.
[SOUND]
[MUSIC]
You can also touch the screen
to browse as well.
So I'll pick something
in the rock genre.
[MUSIC]
And there you go, it's that easy to use,
and in this lesson,
I'm going to show you how
we implement all of this.
We're going to explain how to use
the Android media browsing framework.
We're going to walk you through
a short sample that implements
basic functionality, and
then, how to implement a full
featured media playing application
that works on Android Auto as well
as lots of other platforms as well.